[Music]
killings are up
50 from before covid
where is this coming from remember in
georgia
we were opened up before the rest of the
country
so our nightclubs and our bars remain
open we have people traveling here from
across the country
to party in our city we believe
that getting at least 1 000 young people
to work this summer will help but
there's still so much work to be done
and until we deal with the systemic
issues
of gun violence in this country how
easily
young people people with mental
illnesses can access
guns in this country that's atlanta's
mayor
pointing blame for her city surging
crime rate our next guest firing back
calling out the left's anti-police soft
on crime agenda
georgia governor brian kemp joins us
right now with more governor good
morning to you
hey good morning guys good morning so
she's blaming everybody
except her policies you know she's
talking about well we were
thanks to your policies uh georgia
reopened before a lot of other places
but and she's saying that's why there's
such a surge in crime
but you look to the state to the south
of you florida
i don't see similar numbers there
well look colorado oklahoma there were
plenty of other states south dakota
dakota
was open you know people are tired of
leaders blaming somebody else for
problems that they have
in their own jurisdiction quite honestly
i know i'm fed up with it for two months
we've had a crime suppression unit
working using extra state resources
emergency funding to try to help with
the problem because i hear about it
every single day
and in just two months by putting boots
on the ground officers on the street
and in the air and working with state
and local partnerships we've done almost
3 100 arrests
we've apprehended 71 people who had
outstanding warrants and we've impounded
almost 300 vehicles going after street
crimes
and we're not blaming that on anybody
else we're just doing something about it
in this time
that she did as well well if you look at
buckhead murder is up almost 50 percent
which is that neighborhood in
downtown atlanta robberies aggravated
assaults up nearly 40 percent car
thefts up 65 percent linux square mall
gunfire at the cheesecake factory macy's
employee shot gun battle outside of
bloomingdale's
in april a 60 year old woman severely
beaten in the parking lot and they took
her purse
a few weeks ago two 15 year olds shot
and almost killed a security guard at
the apple store
what's the real reason for all of this
crime
hey look people shouldn't be scared
because they want to simply go get gas
in broad daylight
we focused on buckhead this weekend we
stayed out
late you know the the bars have been or
at least some
bars have been associated with a lot of
these
gatherings of a lot of people well you
know what
we were policing those when they closed
this weekend and it was very
effective tactic uh in fact the atlanta
police department was thanking us for
their partnership over the weekend
you know we've got to start tackling the
problem where it happens they know where
it is
they need someone to back their law
enforcement agency up back the men and
women on the street up
and give them direction to go after
these folks and send a message that's
what i've told our folks
we've got a great partnership with the
atlanta police department
but they're having to ride with us
because they can't chase anybody
it's hard to go after violent criminals
when they run away from you you can't
chase them
you obviously have to be very smart
about that
you know i think there's a lot of
reasons that you could potentially have
this happening
but the fact is there's one way to stop
it and that's to go after them and send
a message and say look we're not going
to put up with this anymore
and you know the judicial system in
fulton county is a source of problem
with this
as well with the revolving door of these
career criminals continuing to get
out of jail the next day and we're
chasing them again
yeah i mean the numbers are stunning and
we went over in the first hour in case
you missed it
atlanta homicides are up 58 shootings up
40 new york city
13 shootings up 64 percent the most
egregious portland we've been watching
it
it's up 533 with shootings up 126
it's very consistent uh it's a very uh
permissive
attorney general district attorney and
there's a mayor who blames the cops
first
and uh crime and crime is just a symptom
of bad policing
no one's buying it it's not making the
average person safe
and i just wonder when the backlash will
begin but i want to talk about something
else when we talk about elections
uh obviously the former president is
very critical of you guys
for um what happened after the election
obviously there's still a conflict there
but one thing that happened over the
weekend
is that going through the voter rolls
between
unresponsive people people moving unable
to validate ids
you've removed a hundred thousand
outdated name from your voter rolls
people are saying that's an example of
voter suppression
what's your answer to that
well brian first of all let me just say
about the last topic the new fulton
county sheriff and the new district
attorney thankfully
are supportive of going after violent
crime so i want to make that point
look us making sure the voter rolls are
updated and secure
lists maintenance we're following
federal law in this state i did that for
nine years when i was secretary of state
the left was outraged as as well they
act like nobody ever moves out of the
state and doesn't notify the secretary
of state's office they're moving
so i think it's pertinent for the
secretary of state's office to be
following federal law when it comes to
less maintenance and keeping our roles
updated you also need to remove deceased
voters and things of that nature
this has been practiced not only in
georgia but many other states around the
country
and it's just another example of these
hollow talking points of the democrats
that are
really being hypocritical if you think
about stacey abrams who said our
new voting law was jim crow 2.0 you know
a month month and a half ago
and now she's saying things like 15 days
of early voting and
uh voter identification when you vote
are perfectly fine
when it's joe manchin's bill and it's a
compromise at the federal level well
they can't have it both ways
in georgia it's easy to vote and hard to
cheat there you go
new york's just wrapping up early voting
here i think they only had seven days
you've got twice as many down in georgia
governor real quick uh i don't know how
much time you spend on twitter
but herschel walker the legendary
football player
put this out and we want you to kind of
figure out what he's talking about
look here
hey what you hear there is hulk
that's what i call it you know
[Music]
he's ready i'm getting ready
and we can run with the big dogs
so either he's going to open a car
dealership
or he's going to run for office what do
you think
well one thing about herself he's a damn
good dog
you know great american but you also
never know what he's gonna do he keeps
people thinking
and um you know i'm sure a lot of people
saw that and are wondering
you know what he's gonna do but one
thing about herself he's an independent
person he'll do what he
he feels is right and his heart and his
mind and we'll see what happens
you want him to run well look i think he
brings a lot to the table
you know running statewide in this
environment is very tough as you know
and
you know you got to have it in your
heart you got to have it in your gut
and that's a decision that he will have
to make he is so loved throughout the
country but especially in your state
right i think he's going to do it thank
you so much governor
have a great day you too